we're gonna put more games to get
through next up dishonored dos oh my God
look like they're any cold winds back as
well uh who's the biggest dishonored
found here let's go all right go go for
what you think um I'm I'm really excited
I'm really glad that it's not it's
technically that it it picks up from the
last game like I really like the world I
was hoping for a prequel but I the idea
that you get to play as Emily who I'm
not going to spoil it because they
announced dishonored definitive edition
they did so if you haven't yet it's
coming to playstation 4 and xbox one so
I won't spoil it but emily is a very
important character from the first game
that doesn't get a lot of not a lot of
spotlight yeah and I'm also very very
excited that they showcased her in the
trailer you can play as Emily or as
Corvo but they focused on her and it
reminded me i hate to call this out but
it reminded me of the syndicate reveal
Assassin's Creed syndicate where you
have the male and female playable
protagonist but they led with Jacob
which is the boy I really liked what I
saw so you can place both her I'm Corvo
in it either or I think you get to pick
um it looks great it looks like the
world has sort of checked up a little
bit it looks a little bit more evolved
from the last game um I'm really excited
to see where this goes story-wise cuz
the narrative was one of my favorite
things about dishonored speaking of that
does this look like the same city same
environment that was in the first game
no this looks entirely different oh yeah
obviously it's a CG trailer so we can't
really take yes you were mad but it
looks thematically similar but a very
very different aesthetic and we were
talking before the show and live about
how the dishonored came out and had a
great sort of an art style to it but
maybe technically didn't wow us and the
ways that we would have hoped especially
were probably because at the end of that
generation those consoles were looking a
little bit light in terms of technical
pro eyes and but in terms of gameplay
and why not here was there anything else
that stood out to you guys in terms of
like the weapons the power is that Emily
was wielding she's the smoke monster
from lost apparently yeah she's got
Jackie Estacado as darkness beings or
something happening oh it was cool I
mean obviously we saw a look at I think
she had the blink she had the time
slowed down she also has some kind of
like grappling hook hmm I'm just used to
scale across buildings there
and obviously the crossbow which core
values to graphite oh there it is there
it is come out of head yeah it looks
like it comes from like prototype yeah
um but yeah it looks cool and I me I'm
yeah I'm just excited to see more really
we don't have a date on this one as of
yet but they did said that no they
didn't say spring no they said did you
say look at the wrong note PC Xbox
Playstation and dishonored definitive
edition which interestingly enough who
called us at and that there was somebody
who said it to us beforehand yes Phil
wait 75 before the show said do you
think they'll be a decided to remaster
and yeah called it so we don't have an
HD version of this honored and coming
out to playstation 4 xbox one did they
say pc for that one as well alright so
you can pay your HD finally play this on
it in HD as this year and yeah and
that's that's pretty much all that
happened here at the Bethesda coffers
somewhat a little bits and bobs and but
I a dishonored was probably another one
of the biggest games so yeah for
continuing coverage of dishonored and
all the other games but that's a show
off here and all the games we're gonna
have 83 make sure you stay tuned to
gamespot com